bonjour monsieur a rigolé rose merci
d'être avec nous sur arte france alors
on vient de le dire
victoire revendiquée par les deux
candidats formation manifestement de
deux gouvernements parallèles
est-ce que abdullah abdullah comme en
2014 à finir par lâcher prise
ou est-ce que la crise politique sera
pire qu'en 2014
elle est on retrouve les mêmes
paramètres qu'en 2014 effectivement les
accusations de fraude électorale qui en
l'espèce joue plutôt sur la comptabilité
début des votes électroniques et non pas
sur les bulletins physique mais en tout
état de cause
ça a été un argument qui a justifié
effectivement l'invalidation de près
d'un million de bulletins et donc ça
hypothèque eux la suite des événements
ce qui explique qu'on retrouve le même
dilemme une certaine manière entre
effectivement ashraf ghani et puis nous
la joue là c'est d'autant plus
problématique que les américains sont en
train de négocier évidemment avec les
talibans et que se posera une fille née
dans le processus la question de la
représentativité pour un dialogue intra
afghan qui est censé être la troisième
étape du processus qui a été mis en
place dans le prolongement des
négociations à doha alors justement
etats-unis les talibans se disent
proches d'un accord les américains vont
retirer leurs troupes en échange d'une
réduction des violences des talibans et
en échange également que les talibans
s'assoie à la table des pourparlers avec
les autorités afghanes
à quel point cette crise politique
afghane fragilise tels les accords de
paix qui vont être négociée avec les
talibans
alors il et fragilise de manière
relative parce que l'un des griefs
justement du président sera fera ni
c'est d'avoir été jusqu'à présent un peu
laissé à la marge des négociations
directes entre les talibans et les
américains le processus de ces
négociations s'est poursuivie d'une
certaine manière sans l'aval et parfois
même sur les consultations en tout cas
pas a priori du gouvernement afghan
il n'en reste pas moins que
les américains ont besoin quand même
d'un gouvernement qui soit susceptible
de négocier après dans le cadre d'un
dialogue entre afghans puisque dans les
négociations de doha ont été prévus
trois étapes en fait la première étant
cessez le feu qui serait une mesure de
confiance demandé par les américains sur
une semaine et à l'issue de cette mesure
de confiance si le cessez le feu était
effectif
il y aurait la possibilité effectivement
d'aller vers la signature d'un accord
dont les paramètres on était déjà assez
largement des établis entre les deux
parties avec une troisième étape
justement qu'ils poseraient la question
du droit du dialogue intra afghan qui
est une nécessité pour aboutir et
finaliser ce processus et c'est là où on
retrouve effectivement la crise actuelle
alors qu'elle est justement le rôle des
états unis dans cette crise afghane kam
est véritablement leur marge de
manoeuvre dans ce conflit la marge de
manoeuvre en réalité il ya une constante
c'est que les états unis en tout cas par
la voix de leur président donald trump
ont décidé de sortir d'afghanistan
ça a été annoncé à plusieurs reprises
alors il ya eu des hauts et des bas
puisque le président donald trump le 7
septembre dernier avait brutalement
annulé le processus au motif que les
talibans n'avaient pas fait montre d'un
engagement vis-à-vis d'un cessez le feu
mais en même temps mike pompéo avait dit
peu de temps après qu'il de mai n'était
pas pessimiste sur la reprise éventuelle
qui sait qui c'est fait effectivement
négociations en novembre et on voit
aujourd'hui que le processus est très
avancé parce que d'ailleurs selon les
termes mêmes de président à président
donald trump
on serait très proche d'un accord le
problème c'est que pour que cet accord
soit une réussite d'une certaine manière
avec une photo comme les aime de malte
rock il faut que y est aussi un
partenaire au niveau de la
représentation officielle du
gouvernement avant avec la
présidentielle du 28 septembre 2019
hélas en bute sur ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui est donc on imagine que les
américains vont faire évidemment de
pression sur pour résoudre le problème
david rigaud les roses merci d'avoir été
avec moi je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur à l'iris en céquami face et
rédacteur en chef de la revue orient
stratégique merci